singer and actor Jessie smell eggs
banked fans for their support at his
first public appearance since he said he
was attacked our partners our
entertainment tonight captured this
video of Smollett at a Los Angeles
performance over the weekend police are
investigating last Tuesday's incident in
Chicago as a possible hate crime Dean
Reynolds shows us the empire star's
message to the men who he says beat him
Jessi Smollett returned to the stage
Saturday for the first time since last
week's incident he offered a defiant
message fighting back against the men he
says attacked him after his said
Smollett who is openly gay also shared
new details on the possible hate crime
on Tuesday morning he told officers two
men beat him splashed him with a
chemical substance and put a noose
around his neck in an attack near his
Chicago apartment he later said they
were yelling this is mega country a
reference to the president's campaign
slogan over the weekend police gathered
new surveillance video from the
apartment building where Smollett lives
a nearby hotel and traffic cameras in
the area so far police say they've
spotted two men in the vicinity where
the attack was reported but have not
found video of the incident
Smollett told his fans he's focused on
moving forward for CBS this morning Dean
Reynolds I know there are a lot of
questions in this case but I know Jesse
Smollett is a really really good guy I
just want justice to be served in this
case you know the investigation of
course is still under way I'm just glad
he's all right really glad he's okay
everybody cooperate with the police and
the police say he's in he's cooperating
with in every step of this investigation